Hello everybody, hi, hi, the game, I gotta get, uh, the game is, uh, oh, somewhere.
The game is somewhere, right now we're in the void.
Ooh, how spooky the void.
Woo, welcome back to Indiana Jones.
Jones Lego Indiana Jones and today we're gonna finish it we're gonna beat the game baby we're on the last movie so we'll do that and um yeah I love the void you do OBS why did it have to be OBS for those for those wondering why the game isn't up it's because um it's because I updated OBS today and i have a stream deck right okay i have a stream deck which if you don't know what it is it's like uh it's like a little how do you describe it it has buttons it's a it's a thing that has buttons yeah it's a little gizmo hot keys that is actually the best way to put it it's hot keys and you can like you can program it to obs and so like i have my different OBS scenes,
which if I were to click something, it would change the scene, but I think the OBS update broke it.
Sad, so sad.
And because of the nature of this game, if I click out, if I click out of it, the game messes all up and messes up my computer.
So, um, I updated OBS today.
You have chosen poorly.
Don't blame, you're victim blaming right now.
I hope you know that.
You're victim blaming me right now.
This is messed up.
It's a...
Imagine trusting OBS updates.
I know, right?
My goodness.
But, it's fine.
But...
uh what was i saying um oh yeah now now my hotkeys don't work i wonder if they work here oh they should oh yeah yeah yeah i could still change my hair it's just obs it gives me a big old fat like exclamation point so updating obs is proof that she hates us
Oh yeah, yeah, those exclamation points.
Yes, yes, yes.
But, um, I should still be able to play.
Hopefully, hopefully my controller works.
That's the thing.
Now, the same thing happened with my Stream Deck.
The solution was to delete and reinstall the OBS plugin, which in turn required me to update the Stream Deck software.
No, I refuse.
I refuse to update.
Kiwawa!
Direct!
Oh my gosh, wait.
did you have the most fun with clover pit because i'm obsessed with that game right now i played it yesterday hello kfp welcome in welcome hello hello my love gamble is live it's so fun oh my gosh i was like lukewarm on belatro just because like of the the the the poker aspect of it i don't know anything about poker but this game oh oh oh it's so fun i was watching a little bit of you earlier kiwama i i wanted to go with i wanted to chat and be like all in all in all in
but yeah oh my gosh i can't i'm playing clover pit again later this week too it's so fun it's so fun thank you guys for the for the for the um gift thank you same about poker but did you try belacho at all because i don't know anything about cards but belacho was it was fun don't get me don't get me wrong i'm just not good very with numbers i get i see numbers and i get very scared i get scared well hi guys i was just i was just lamenting about obs and my broken um stream deck at the moment uh because obs updated and um now i can't use my stream deck and i'm playing an old game today we're playing lego indiana jones if you know the indiana jones trilogy movies were on the last crusade i got scared of my trillions and clover pit too trillions send me your okay i'm gonna watch i'm gonna i'm gonna watch the vaude i need to know your build what i saw that you had the lucky cat and lucky cat is so awesome trillions she made it a long ways that's my that's my that's my queen she's so smart
she is the blueprint you guys the blueprints like she she has everything on her side now it was like e plus 22 what the hell oh my god oh my god
she's she's a gamer kiwa was great though with puzzle games i think condolences on being Goomba.
I don't mind this.
I'm fine.
I'm not even a little sad about it.
Don't worry.
Me finishing all the smart people games.
Meanwhile, Min plays Lego.
Okay, but Lego is fine.
It's fine.
Okay, I like Legos.
I like Legos.
Okay, we're going to get the Lego set up because, okay, hopefully this doesn't break.
Let's try.
Let's see if old game participates.
Oh!
Wait.
Uh...
Wait, hold on.
My controller's not working.
No, no, no, no, no!
Cancel, cancel, cancel!
Wait, exit.
Uh-oh, wait.
Uh-oh.
Oh, no, no, no.
Okay, cancel.
Yes.
I have to quit.
I have to quit the game Oh gosh Everything Everything gets wacky Everything gets wacky wacky Okay I restart We redo, reload, retry And my controller's on And okay Everything is still placement Fine Okay Oh, yay!
But when you click the load, my Firefox crashed.
I'm haunting your computer?
Okay, Indiana Jones.
Oh, my controller's working.
Okay, we're at home right now.
This is me.
I'm going to turn it down just a little bit.
Let me collect my riches.
Let me...
Okay, hold on.
I mean, remember how to play.
We can beat things up, you guys.
We can destroy everything.
The wonders of Legos is being able to massacre without worry.
Wait.
We'll get her.
Wait, how do I...
Wait, hold on.
I can kiss her, right?
No, come here.
Not the monkey.
Come here, come here, babe.
Come here.
Come here, hot stuff, sweet thing.
Why can't I kiss her?
Wait, why can't I kiss her?
Oh!
She hates me.
She's not interested.
That's fine.
Consent is hot.
I didn't want her anyway.
I don't want her anyway.
It's fine.
One more try.
She's not even looking.
Wait, is this...
Wait!
I think she's the one I can kiss.
Nope, I'm destroying.
No, come back.
Why doesn't anybody...
Why doesn't anybody want me?
Please, please, please.
Hold on.
Look at the way this guy is walking around.
It's so funny.
They all want Goomba.
Not Goomba.
Wait, one more try.
Oh my god, I
just...
Please, ma'am, please!
Look at my fists!
I'm so strong!
Isn't that sexy?
Maybe because you keep whipping them.
No, no, no!
That's what they like!
That's how they... That's...
What they want!
That's what they want!
Trust, trust, trust.
Alright.
Lessons in Women.
Given to you?
By Mint Fan Code.
shushed yeah it's willy right she was willy in her oh we have like no money
willy please there's gotta be someone in here that loves me maybe we should just play the game maybe we should just play the game well I'm collecting money right I'm gathering my riches.
This is the game.
Okay, one more try.
Okay, wait.
I didn't beat to do that.
I thought I was about to kiss him.
For real.
I thought I was about to kiss him for real.
That was terrifying.
Okay, it's fine.
Let's just keep going.
Sweet hat, though.
Yeah, we took it.
We robbed him.
We murdered him and robbed him.
Why is a monkey move like that?
Shiver me timbers.
Alright.
Last movie!
Last crusade!
Let's go!
Because he's a Chadian.
The hunt for Sir Richard.
Isn't it in here?
Or am I crazy?
Am I thinking of another movie?
I can't remember.
Hmm.
Minecraft villager noises.
The photo is so silly.
Oh, wait.
This is Sean Connery, isn't it?
Sean Connery.
Lego Sean Connery.
Oh, it's this guy, too.
I remember him.
Sean Connery, big boss.
Lego, Lego big boss.
Oh, why are they acting so suspicious?
Well, you weren't reading anything bad, were you?
These Lego turned on?
Aha!
Oh, tickets!
They were reading.
I'm getting thin bucks.
Oh, okay.
Oh, wait, maybe it's her.
That I was...
I thought it was Willy that I was trying to go for before, or maybe not.
Gonna show the double dip.
Is Lego not interested?
Oh my god!
Whoa!
Wait.
No, come on.
Take her.
Take her into your arms.
What?
Oh my gosh.
Oopsie.
Wait, how do I get out of the water?
Wait, somebody, please.
Please, I'm Lego drowning.
Someone grab my hand.
No!
Wait, how do I get out?
Uh-oh.
Wait, she's awesome.
Wait, why did you guys Let's jump in here with me.
Uh-oh.
There's gotta be.
Oh, here we go.
Here we go.
Hot dog indeed.
There we go.
Okay.
We're fine.
Everything's fine.
Oh no.
I forgot to set it so...
I'm so sorry.
I cannot see the...
Oh no.
Because I forgot to set it.
I'm so sorry.
Thank you.
I saw a Goomba fan.
This I can grab.
Alright.
What else is...
Oh, okay.
Um, where's my hot girlfriend?
She's swimming in circles?
Oh.
Oh, she wants to go in the gondola.
I get it.
Oh, never mind.
I'm her now.
Oh.
I thought she can jump higher.
Well, we do need her anyway for this part right here.
Ah, she jumps up here.
Ha ha ha ha.
No, no, no.
Okay, I see that in there.
Oh!
I'm getting used to the controls again.
Can I get up even further?
Okay.
Okay, maybe like here.
Oh, dang it.
Whoa!
Even further beyond.
Okay, we're gonna do it again.
Hold on.
I'm gonna make this.
I...
Oh, wait.
Maybe if I, like, stand...
Oh, okay, hold on.
Like this.
Ah-ha!
But...
But, the issue is I don't know how to get inside.
The window?
It's a mystery to me.
Can she scream?
Oh, what's... Yeah, what's...
Oh, uh...
She pulls out a book.
Yeah, that's right.
If Willy could scream, she would just...
It was horrible.
It was so bad.
Okay, good.
We got these now.
She's so...
Her punches are so slow.
It's kind of funny.
All right, all right, all right, all right, all right, all right.
adventurer because of collecting so much stuff.
Damn, the girls here are stylish.
Oh, oops.
I'm so sorry.
Oh, my God.
Oh, she was a citizen.
Oopsie.
Oh, I don't know my own strength.
Oh, my gosh.
I feel like I could jump onto that.
And I don't know, though.
Oopsie, yep, just a little silly.
A little silly mishap, you know.
Totally on accident.
What I love about this game is you can literally destroy everything.
What does the book do?
I think it translates stuff, I think.
Oops, oh my gosh, my depth perception.
Sorry, I had to take it out on somebody.
Where's Indy?
See, oh, he's doing laps, too.
Like, I want to jump on that, but I guess I can't.
Okay.
I think I can also destroy the Indy.
I can.
There's so much to destroy.
Lap!
Legol!
I feel like Godzilla.
Okay, we got this.
Sorry for any KFP watching me game for the first time.
My depth perception is a little...
You could say lacking.
You could say...
A little troubled.
Perhaps...
Yeah.
What is this?
Oh, oh, Indy!
What does this guy do?
And he's also got his little book, okay?
Wait, it won't let me be Indy.
Uh-oh.
No, Indy, I need you.
Okay, there we go.
Alright, it's your turn in the pool.
In the canals of...
Where are we?
Do you think you'll play other Lego games?
I had this on my DS, and every character had the same death sound in a minigame for children's braids.
I...
Okay, you guys, I'm gonna be 100% honest with you here.
Um, I don't know what it is about this game, but it gives me a terrible headache.
I don't know what it is.
Like, I've just kind of been going through it.
The first time I noticed it, I thought, oh, maybe I was tired or something that day, but then it happened again the second time.
And I was just like, what?
Oh my gosh, look at the peace!
It's a...
Hoop!
It's probably the frame rate.
It might be.
It's like... I think it's...
It's really something.
I wish I didn't have to play it full screen, because I think that would help me as well.
But the game just...
Oh, I thought they were coming.
I thought they were coming to kill me!
We're fine.
Everything's fine.
Why can't I jump?
Hello?
Oh, there we go.
So yeah, um, I guess this is an older game, so it's not that the other Lego games will look like this, probably, but I just to consider i just want to you know be careful about it for other future games is all i don't know what it is i was like this this game and i'm even like i'm feeling it now i just kind of like just kind of deal with it i've just been kind of dealing with it it's no biggie oh we need a small person we need we need our guy
but yeah i don't want to complain about it so much i just wanted to let you guys know um how i was feeling about it is all oh i need that in there how
do i get in there
destroy oh it's so easy
nice oh um nope nope just kidding we go.
All right, team.
Yay!
Team!
What else do we got?
Oh, we have some bikes.
Nobody will enjoy this establishment ever again.
Nobody will enjoy the parks.
No one will enjoy the view.
I like the view.
They're my best view.
animator dom i'm so sorry i didn't get to see what your super chat said but happy birthday happy happy birthday oh they have to translate that up there okay okay i see i see all right miss lady all right okay i got this i got this oh i'm glad i had that because i was half paying I wasn't really watching the screen.
We're all good, though.
Everything's fine.
Why won't you let me have a car?
A bike.
Okie dokie.
stuff up here i think we need yeah uh we need we need shorty or someone oh that's right it's in here
oops no no that's not what i wanted to do not yet oh actually that is what i want to do
books no we love books what are you talking about Oh, what is this?
I love when they, like, throw hands, but it just...
They don't do anything.
They're like...
But there's...
They don't do anything, you know?
I hate books!
Oh!
Library!
Uh, no way that guy was gonna go sit in that one lonesome chair.
Just punch in air.
It looks like they're showing off, but like to who?
You know?
Like, who?
Oh!
Ah!
Wait, this is a real secret!
I might be the best professor ever!
Oh, nice.
If you want to resize the game but doesn't have an option, there's a free program called Sizer.
I've heard of several games, like several programs before.
Sometimes they work for me.
Sometimes they don't.
But I will look into that one as well.
Thank you so much.
I really appreciate it.
Because, yeah.
There's been like a couple.
Sweiser.
I hardly even know her.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, wrong way.
Oh, how cute!
Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
Okay, this is a two-person operation.
Everybody, please cooperate.
No, no, no.
Come on.
Come on, everybody.
I could use some help.
Just kidding.
These are some bizarre looking flowers.
I will say that.
awfully funky looking gotta love the music this game this game gets me copyright I think because it uses like the actual theme I get copyright struck every time well it's not like a strike it's like a you can't monetize this game but I'm afraid I was told recently that if you have too many of those like too many of the you can't monetize this game type games or type streams that they will take away your like ships and stuff.
I don't know if that's real or not.
That scares me.
Oh, I like my emotes.
So yeah, maybe I have to be careful.
I used to be like, oh, I don't care if a game gets demonetized or whatever, but I might have to be careful about like just for that, you know?
You took so scary!
Yeah, I was talking to my friend about it last night, actually.
She was like, I can't monetize my...
Or I can't open memberships because of, like, pre-existing...
What's the words?
Copyright thingamababs.
They're not strikes, I think?
I don't know what to describe it as.
Just, like, claims, maybe.
What's in here?
Oh, hold on.
We need a lady's touch.
She got this.
She does not got this.
She's like going around in circles.
Oh, actually, I do need you to translate.
Ha.
Okay.
Wait, what was it this?
Ugh.
Oh, okay, good.
Play Indiana Jones in the Emperor's Tomb.
Except before Indiana Jones in the Temple of Doom.
Kind of rash.
Sick bars.
Hmm.
Okay, we got the last one.
What are these swords for?
Huh.
Oh.
Do I throw?
I think I throw it.
I think there's probably two of them.
Two of them, two of them, two of them, two of them.
Maybe?
Hiya!
Yeah!
We're so good.
Oh, we're so good at video game.
Oh yeah, baby.
Nope.
Put that book away.
I don't want to read.
Oh, what's over here?
Okay.
All right.
More over here.
Maybe I need a lady's touch.
Okay.
She can jump real good.
Nope.
Not good enough.
Cool.
Have you streamed skate?
The new one?
Oh my gosh.
gosh, I kind of wanted to, but I'm not very keen on it being only online.
You know what I mean?
Like...
I don't like that part about it.
Oh!
I got one!
I missed 30 minutes!
Oh, my favorite ghost mid-Eushie playing a game I love?
Ah, you're just in time!
Don't worry!
Yeah, I think only online games i mean everybody i think has the same kind of sentiment about it where it's like once the game goes offline you can't play the game anymore and that just sucks you know
so yeah i don't know i was like pretty excited about it and then i saw that i was like oh no
That's kind of sad, kind of stinky.
Oh!
We just had to be patient.
I see.
All right, back to Indy.
X marks the spot.
Monkey.
Monkey sounds.
Nice.
what we build in here.
What's up there?
Oh, I don't have a hat!
Dang it.
So what those things are, are if you wear the hat of, like, the character that's there.
So it would be that hat.
I guess they'll give you something.
I'm not quite sure.
Wait, there's more fountain here.
What is this?
What are these for?
There's so much around here also.
I don't get it.
I actually don't understand it.
Decoration?
No, this is definitely alluding to some sort of puzzle something something.
It's fine.
Oh, we're just causing vandalism.
Wait, are we gonna see, isn't there a little...
What was down here?
This part was kind of...
This part was cool.
It was the rat!
She's such a little trickster.
I guess it's a turnoff for him.
He's like, I hate when my girls play tricks.
I only like when my girls stay sexy.
That was close.
Oh my gosh, okay, that's exciting.
So if we find five skulls, okay, that was a trap.
No worries.
Oh!
Oh my gosh, I'm stuck in a death loop.
Oh god, okay, you guys.
Oh, that was bad.
That was pretty bad.
That was quite bad.
This one is definitely has a skelly in it.
Oh, okay.
Did not have a skelly in it.
Bye!
These are terrifying now.
Wait, did we push it or pull it?
Will we pull in it?
Hey!
Second skellar.
Wait, aren't I supposed to dig here?
Oh, there we go.
Okay, we got a thing.
Yes.
The music is so mysterious.
This game was my childhood growing up.
First game I have my Xbox 360 along with Kung Fu Panda.
Also, Dwargo, thank you so much!
Oh, for the five gifted thank you.
Oh, that is quite the platform.
How do I open these up, too?
And then we have this here, another platform, it seems.
Trying to get my brother Dallas to watch you because you love Metal Gear.
He doesn't watch YouTubers.
Could you give him some wisdom?
He doesn't watch V-Tubers.
And you're trying to taint him?
He doesn't watch V-Tubers and you're trying to...
Get him to the dark side?
Hmm.
Wisdom.
I do love Metal Gear.
I think Metal Gear is good wisdom.
Oh, neat.
That was such good timing for the music.
I think my wisdom would be stop while you're ahead.
Oh, I thought Indy just exploded.
There's the rats.
Spikes.
Oh, she's afraid of rats.
Okay.
Each little character's got their own thing that they get spooked about.
Indy doesn't care about rats.
Oh, yes, he does.
Okay, just kidding.
I was wrong.
I was very wrong.
Okay, uh...
What is this thing here?
Oh, my gosh!
I just adjusted the camera a little bit.
I'm gonna lose all of my body.
I see that there, but I don't think I can grab it.
Like the rope up top.
She gets too scared.
She won't do anything.
Hmm.
What are the rats gonna do with my money anyway?
What do they want with it?
Well, I'm gonna try and get into there.
Oh.
Maybe Indy can.
I give up.
Oh!
There's also here.
Oh, oh.
Oh, see, because there's a blue in there.
Is there anything else I missed over here, or did I get everything?
I thought I got it all.
Oh, my God.
I'm a big old loser.
Oh,
okay, we need three more skellies.
Let's see.
Did we see any, um, what's it called?
Torches.
And it torches around.
That I could snatch.
No.
None, it seems.
Can you break those pot things?
I was trying too!
The ones on the wall, right?
Please.
Look how cute the rats are though.
They're kind of cute.
See, it doesn't break.
It looks like it would, right?
Oh my god.
He's so sensitive!
Andy, be careful!
in the end of Jones.
He jumped over the gap.
I guess that's my only option that I can think of.
Oh, it was not nearly as big as I thought it was.
Let's go.
Oh, I need her.
I need you.
I need you, lady.
I don't remember her name.
Good job.
Good job, team.
Yippee!
Oh, it's Elsa.
Elsa, thank you guys.
Elsa Frozen.
What is in there?
Oh, oh!
I think we got our next guy.
Awesome.
Can I destroy him?
Nope, lucky.
Let's go.
Onwards, onwards.
okay so we can fall into this water oh good thing someone just got monetization delayed from youtube strike for using a gif i made of you what wait also destruction destruct shan happy birthday relative oh instead of singing happy birthday could you say in a relatively monotone voice happy birthday
Was that good enough?
Skelly!
Nope.
Just kidding.
Oh my god!
Indiana Jones, you scared the heck out of me!
Why would you do that?
Oh my gosh!
How did you get up there?
Oh!
Scared me!
Is this a timer or...
Oh, okay, it's a timer for that thing, so we don't need to worry about it.
We are all too big for that.
Now, what is this?
Hmm.
What is...
What all do we have going on around here?
Oh, I can throw it at the way.
Wait, wrong button.
Oops, wrong button again.
Please, please, please, please.
There we go.
Aha!
Nope.
But now what?
Oh!
Oopsie.
Oh, there's like a bunch of stuff down there.
Okay, interesting.
Interesting, interesting.
So much stuff around here.
Yeah, collected.
Yeah, just keep collecting.
Yeah, get real close.
Okay.
Oh, I probably need to do it from up here.
Okay, so I need...
I need you, Elsa.
There was a web earlier in the catacomb as well.
Wait, I've seen a couple webs.
Anything that you think has been so pertinent that...
No, no, why would you do that, you stupid?
What's this?
Oh?
Cool.
There was stuff under here, though.
Can I dive?
Dive, dive, dive.
Oh, I can dive.
I think.
Was that diving?
Yes.
Oh, nice.
Yeah, good job, Bindy.
Can you breathe?
That looks like...
I think I see a skelly in there.
Wait, can we get these down here?
The water?
I don't...
It's like...
I think it's so filled with decomposition.
It's like terrible.
Oh, okay.
I moved them somehow.
I think I have to get them all in one go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I have to get it all in one go.
Okay, we got this.
We got this.
Out of my way!
There he is!
Oh,
it's so sad.
Little pathetic guy.
Why is it just so oily looking?
Like, you know, I guess the realism, but they really didn't need it, did they?
They didn't need to do it like that, did they?
Where am I pushing this, Joe?
Oh, okay, okay.
Oh, no, I'm not trying to play chess.
I think I need to push it onto here, though.
Alright, move, madame.
Oh, it's slippery.
Oh, from all the body slime!
Ma'am?
Ma'am.
It's already tough to walk.
I'm like, slower, you know?
Oh.
Oh, the goo!
The goo is doing wonders in here.
Okay.
Alright, nice.
Just a little bit more.
Nice.
A little bit more.
Oh, hi!
We got half a stair.
All the ectoplasm?
You wish.
This looks like ectoplasm right here, though.
Not gonna lie.
Looks mighty.
Suspicious.
How?
Do we get up there?
Oh, I use this guy.
I use this guy's dead body.
Maybe her.
Okay.
Oh, nice.
There we go.
It's not yours, is it?
What if it was?
Would you drink the ectoplasm water?
And then this.
Let me just push a little to the left.
And then...
And a little forward.
And she's in!
Nice.
Yeah, you would?
Ah!
You don't have to.
Whoa!
Oh, nice.
Okay, handy.
Oh, wait a second.
Can I even like...
Is this gonna be in the way?
Ah, wait.
Because I think I need this to get up there, right?
Maybe?
Probably.
Push, push, push.
Oh, I can't push no more.
Okay, push, push, push.
Why can't I push it to the left?
Need something mint color for my Vito subshaker.
Thank you for ordering it.
There's a little block in front of me.
of it.
Oh, is there?
Oh, gosh.
He pushes so fast, so hard.
Okay, hold on.
Just a little.
Maybe.
Trying to figure out what they...
I don't think he wants me to jump.
I want to go over there, but I think I missed maybe my window of opportunity.
Ah, I think I did.
That's okay.
Oh, oh, oh, so not like a gentleman.
Oh,
wow.
What's going on?
Why are those ladies twins?
Did she just call him over?
Are we just going to allow that?
Don't touch me.
Oh my gosh.
What was happening?
Oh yeah, we gotta get in the boat.
Massacre!
Kill them all!
This is a long chapter.
We're getting Lego killed.
Nice.
Okay.
Lego killed, baby.
Oh, never Lego see again.
Oops, fell in the water.
Wait, what's behind here?
Nothing.
Hold on, I'm getting all my Lego money.
Elsa the Destroyer.
I mean, she destroyed my trust.
If you've seen the movies, you know.
Spoiler alert.
Elsa, the destroyer of trust and hearts.
Alright.
Time to pilot a boat.
Oh.
Oh, she got it.
Oh, they get their own.
Okay, that's cute.
I want to be indie, though.
Yay!
Woo-hoo!
Oh.
Whoopsie.
Never mind, just one out of ten.
Oops.
Two out of ten.
Where did he go?
Oh, that's her.
Okay, you could do anything, Miss Elsa.
You could help at all.
You could have any sense of use.
Urgency?
Oh my gosh.
Ha-ya!
Whoa!
He's on fire!
He's on...
Oh.
Now I gotta go beat his butt.
Oh, but what about these?
I wanna take down all the...
Hold on.
I'm gonna find them all.
Take them down.
Six.
No survivors, miss.
Exactly!
No survivors!
Nine and...
Ten!
Let's go?
What's over on these sides though?
I don't know if we like come back here or...
Or if after we take care of this guy we don't get to come back so I don't want to just
Oh, I feel like we must.
This is all broken.
Okay, I feel like we must.
Probably for like...
Oh, oh, get in.
Oops.
Wait, what just happened?
Oh, our boat, uh, don't worry about it.
I keep pressing Y, but it's not...
Okay, there we go.
Oh, oopsie.
Not my bad.
I knew that was going to happen, and I still...
It's like a ship graveyard in here.
Boat number two.
We hardly knew you.
We're getting all the good stuff.
All the good loot.
All right, now let's go kick this guy's butt!
Don't!
Watch me wobble, okay?
It's kind of embarrassing.
Hey, where are you going?
Why am I just standing here and letting you do it?
Hello?
What are you doing?
A pal!
Oh, come on!
Yeah, I'll take you down.
I knew it was too easy.
Sorry I don't always get all the little coins.
Sometimes I wish I had, like, a bigger range of pickup, you know what I mean?
Hello?
Get in the boat.
There we go.
Hello!
Where are you?
Hello?
Oh, what is she doing?
Well, she's over there, and that guy's dancing.
Oh, there he is.
Nice.
Nice, nice.
Oh, there's three of them!
Uh-oh, I think she's in trouble.
Oh, he's gonna run into the...
No, he's not.
I am good at boat chousing, aren't I?
I spoke too soon, maybe?
I think I have to push him in there.
Oh.
kidding oh hold on man overboard let's
go Indy go and sorry I'm
blocking her face it's me think of Lego Indiana I don't want to think about that I think nothing
my face is better What if I were a Lego lady?
I was so close to being a true adventurer.
So close.
Dang.
We keep on going.
Lego Minto.
That was like the most JPEG image I've ever seen.
Oh.
Ah, ah, ah.
Are we not dressed for the occasion?
Hmm.
Oh, what is happening?
Wait, what is the point?
Oh.
Where did he get the wig from?
Wait, what is...
He's so sassy.
What is happening?
Wait, what is the context?
Because I don't remember this in the film.
You're already a mythical block, lady, so you just have to get a little taller.
True, true.
Oh, yeah.
The Mona, the Lego Mona Lisa!
Oh my gosh, it's so coveted.
Wow.
We're amongst royalty.
Thank you, Lou.
Thank you, thank you.
Could a Lego model like...
Oh yeah, I've seen her.
I've seen Tenma's Lego model.
It's cute.
I forgot she had one.
Is this a sneaking mission?
Why are you shooting actual, like, bazookas in the house?
Oh, my gosh.
I'm taking your hat.
Oh, my money.
My money.
The music seems appropriate for this situation.
Oops, sorry.
Collateral.
She's fine.
I feel like the reward is not worth.
Come on, take it.
One out of four.
Uh-huh.
I see.
Wait, are there special ones?
Perhaps?
Friendly fire.
Oh, I see.
That one.
Aha!
Yeah.
I'm so good!
He pretended to not be Scottish.
Well, he pretended to be a Scottish lord in the movie.
He did not steal her hair.
That one really just kind of...
We stole her hair.
You know, just kind of like, oh.
You go up there.
You grab that.
Nice.
Nice and nice.
Probably need Indy here.
Wait,
are we going out?
Oh!
Hold on!
There's stuff over here?
Okay, I can't use this guy yet.
There's, like, a specific character you use here?
No bald doggle.
I guess I mean, Lego people can switch...
Switch...
He's, like, standing here, like, adjusted.
Look at him.
Lego people can, like, just kind of...
of switch hair and stuff so i guess it makes sense trying to see what this art is i guess it makes sense it's kind of freaky though hello there we go
before he could bazooka me oh wait i'm so good wait i'm too good Don't think about it.
Grab everything.
Grab it all.
Oh.
Do I lose the money?
I think I do.
I should have switched over.
Before she fell.
Okay.
Yeah, you could just switch...
That's kind of convenient.
It's like I'm in the mood for this hat today.
This hair today.
This anything today.
Must be nice to be a little Lego person.
Do I jump over here?
There's this thing.
This is quite mysterious.
Oh, okay.
I don't know why my first instinct was not to destroy it.
Aha!
Okay.
Such force, Indy.
Ah.
Ah, papah!
Oh.
Banana.
Oh, my God.
We got double-crossed.
Why are we...
Why are we still still smiling about that though she just betrayed us no why are we like oh it was worth the kiss now we set the whole place on fire oh okay that spread really quickly okay awesome papa i'm in need of your your expertise middle bottom top middle bottom top lift
I got something.
Oh, it's a bunch of different weapons.
Okay.
We're still in a bit of a pickle.
Wait.
Are you telling me you wouldn't kiss a woman who betrayed you?
I mean, this depends on how pretty she is.
Oh, sorry, Indy.
I'm not saying I wouldn't, but...
Indy, how do we get out of here?
Indy.
What does he do?
Oh, he shoots.
And he scores?
Maybe like this one.
Oh!
Oopsie!
My money is right there.
Get it, Eddie.
Get it.
Lego women be crazy.
It's them dang Lego women.
You're so right.
Trying to figure out what to do here.
Huh.
Okay.
I think I can reach up here.
Oh.
I don't think we can go in the tank.
but it looks quite engulfed in flame.
Punch the chair?
It wouldn't let me.
Oh my gosh.
Now it lets me.
Wow.
That's quite the contraption we got going on.
Okay, cool.
All that for...
All that for just a...
A ladder.
Papa, are you hot?
Nice.
I can't destroy those.
But we can.
Oh, there we go.
Ah!
That does something.
Okay, what does that do?
Oh, he creates a platform.
What does this do?
Oh, there's an even bigger one.
guy!
Alright, we'll have Papa Pole and Indy needs, oh, Indy, uh, someone needs to be on it.
Okay, I can't go around.
Why would he do it though?
Oh my gosh.
Do we need to like destroy books.
I think you need something first.
What else could we get?
Yeah, spear them books.
Spear them.
Whoa!
Oh, okay, I needed this.
That's why.
Aha, aha, aha.
And then he'll probably...
What is... Raise the roof?
Whoop, whoop!
The Navy Indy does this.
Yes.
Oh!
That was close.
That was so close!
Wait, how'd you get up there?
How did you do that?
Wait a second, you're not supposed to be able to do that?
Wait, how did you do that?
Wait, what was the...
Wait!
I just dropped my phone!
How did he do that?
Man's got hops.
Wait, can I make this?
Oh, yes, I can.
Nice.
Okay, this is the one that, like, I remember this part in the movie where they, like, are turning the table around and stuff.
It's funny.
Alright, oh, you, Papa!
Up, kettle, Left.
Okay.
Easy, easy, easy.
Nice, nice, nice.
Oh, we can't go in.
Ah, I got the troop!
Wait already?
That's kind of crazy.
Oh, wrong way.
If we go?
Oh, I'm just destroying everything they have.
Kill!
More communication!
No more technology!
Massacre!
So satisfying.
It's honestly just actually so satisfying.
Where does this go to?
Okay.
His back hurts.
Is there stuff up here or no?
Oh here, this one.
Alright, grandpa!
No survivors.
Destroy all their documents, their secrets.
Destroy their research.
We built the best boombox ever.
Actually, what is this?
Oh!
All about that base.
Which museum does Minto belong?
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Come on, bye-bye!
Yeah, take him out.
Take him out.
What is he...
What are you doing?
He's a radio guy.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, he's gonna call for backup.
Wait, does he actually do that?
I don't like that at all.
Oh,
I gave him a little nuggie.
And then I killed him.
Friendly, friendly battle between guys, you know?
Yeah, hold on, I'm trying to destroy this.
There we go.
I mean, though, hello, hello, hello!
Oh, he's got HP, I just noticed.
We won't let him get away!
Ah!
I'm shooting everybody.
So nice of them to let me...
Take care of their other men before taking care of them.
I lost my hide, so I can't do this.
I always never have a hat.
What museum would I...
Ripley's, believe it or not?
Unironically, I would love to be in there.
I kind of like that place.
It's fun.
I think I would love it.
Actually.
Whoa!
I dodged!
How did I do that?
Okay, cool.
Can I blow these up?
Oh, sorry.
Sorry, Dad.
Wait.
I tried to...
Hold on, my aim.
Watch out, Dad.
Watch out.
Oh.
She's fine.
Okay, no.
No, I'm gonna lose my gun!
Oh, hold on.
Stop.
being weird.
He's like, I'm gonna sneak around.
Oh, ah!
I missed that!
Wait.
Was it over here?
Yes.
There we go.
Oh, I don't think we should have done that!
Oh.
Yeah?
Okay.
I killed them all.
They're all dead.
Everything's good.
We're good, team.
What did that do?
I can't see anything in here.
Go, Grandpa.
What did that do?
I didn't see a hat.
I don't think there was one.
No hat.
So sad.
They gave me guns.
No hat.
I feel like I need to blow these up, but I'm not quite sure.
Oh, dad!
Watch out!
Oh, okay.
Maybe one of these guys have a bazooka?
Oh, wait, he has a hat!
I think it's the wrong hat, though.
Let's try.
My hat is white.
I think it needs to be a black hat.
Are they going to kick my butt.
Hello.
He's nodding?
Just kidding.
We're in.
We're so in.
Let's go.
Dad, watch out.
What did I...
Is that the bazooka I need?
I think so.
Okay, perfect.
I don't want to waste it on this guy.
We're fine.
And can I use it on that?
Wait.
Oh, it did work.
Awesome, awesome, awesome.
Yahoo!
Rocket launcher.
To the rescue.
Oh!
Oopsie.
Okay, you can fall.
Be careful.
Papa, go forward.
Papa, you're trying to sabotage me?
He can handle his own down there.
Oh, they're coming up here.
Oh my god.
Hey, hey, hey.
Oh!
Papa, move.
I need to get the mothman down.
I'll take that.
Mothman.
Oh, nice!
Wait, I didn't think that would give me a...
Wait.
I need another hat.
Wait, what happened to my old hat?
Oh, it's because I died.
Huh.
Hmm.
Oh, yeah, I fell and I died.
Maybe somebody will come back.
Over here.
Maybe if I go up here?
Huh.
Oh, what's he doing over there?
Yeah, he's really freaking it.
Oh, gosh.
The siren will summon another officer.
Oh, okay, okay.
I just didn't want to walk back over top of this because it scares me.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, I set a bullet.
I just tried to get it out.
Ah!
Oh, I see the hat!
Please don't kill me.
Okay, we're fine.
Everything's good.
We're okay.
Everything's fine.
Oh, oh.
Scared me.
You scared me.
Okay.
Don't fall.
Wait.
Alright, Indy, come over here.
Alright, we're good.
Okay.
It's not cheap.
It's not.
No, that's not what I meant to do.
I mean, I guess I could.
Is there anybody in here to shoot?
No, I guess we're okay.
He keeps taking it out.
Stop it, Indy.
Well, I need to be Papa anyway.
Oh, wait.
I've never seen this before.
mysterious.
Why does he keep freaking out like that?
He's scaring me.
Um, oh, okay.
Well, cutscene.
The furniture by the entrance seems glowy.
I need the bazooka to get it, though.
I didn't have it.
I could have gone back and gotten it, but...
It's fine.
It's okay.
Okay, ready for this terrible noise?
Okay, here it comes.
I want to go unlock some guys.
I hope that's okay.
Hello, Papa.
This is my house.
I reside here in the walls.
Oh, I accidentally just got that.
We got Willy in her pajamas.
Okay, if we find Willy, like Shirley, the children are cheap.
But
I want the radio operator, he was so cute.
But look, we almost have everybody unlocked.
Oh, wait, can I kiss you?
Please!
I'm so lonely, I'm gonna keep destroying everything.
So lonely, I'm so lonely.
Nobody wants to kiss me.
Why?
I'll never get the girl!
Oh, snap!
Indy has violent tendencies, everybody.
Don't... don't follow in his actions, okay?
He's just sensitive.
It's not good.
What about one of you?
One of you?
Oh, I'm a plant.
Hold on.
No girl will ever love me.
Indie's my role model!
I like how they have different ways of walking.
Like, it's actually such a small detail.
That they really didn't have to do anything about.
And yet, they did.
It's kind of cute.
Now it's all better for him.
Yeah, he's gotta get a little...
Why won't she love me?
It's because our child is Shia LaBeouf.
So we escaped.
Handy.
Indy was like, can you just wait two?
Freaking seconds?
Papa?
I swear.
Yeah, Indy is truly maidenless.
At least in these games.
I don't think he really cares much, though.
Like, the ladies are trying to be, like, schmoosing on him, and he is just like, uh-uh.
I don't care.
Put it away.
Put that away, Indiana Jones.
Thank you.
Can I destroy this, too?
Oh, I can!
Oh.
Oh, there!
Too busy adventuring.
Adventure.
Adventuring.
Is that right?
Is that correct?
Woo!
We got a bike!
I don't think I can put it together yet.
Oh!
He is an adventure.
What's wrong with the bike that I just unlocked here?
Oh well this one is broken.
What's wrong with this one?
It works perfectly fine.
Adventural ring.
Oh it's just like pushing it along.
Let's see, what else do we need?
What else?
I guess we gotta, oh, we need to put the bikes on these, maybe.
Ah, okay, okay, okay.
Well, uh, he tapped it, so I guess it's fine.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh my gosh.
This is the best part when I can destroy everything so easily.
It feels so good!
It feels so good.
Oh my gosh.
That
way?
Nah, I follow my own road.
Comp it.
So there's this one ride at Tokyo Disneyland.
Sorry, Tokyo Disney Sea.
I was wrong.
Oh, I need to get off the bike.
Where, um...
It's called Sinbad.
And it's like the most... It's like Like if...
If...
What's it called?
It's a small world where any good, you know?
And they have a song in it that's just like...
It's kind of like...
The song is just so actually catchy.
Oh, okay, these do hurt.
Just kidding.
And part of it is talking about...
The compass of your heart!
And the song is like...
Wait, no, it's...
Life is an adventure and...
Oh!
My bike!
Oh, okay, it's fine.
Just kidding, sorry.
I didn't mean to scream.
We were never seeing it again.
I was really scared.
So yeah, it's like, life is an adventure, and there's no...
There's no map, but you just follow the compass of your heart.
Why did I bring this up?
Oh, I died.
Oh, I'm stuck in a death loop.
Wait, Indy, don't do it.
Indy, don't do it.
Okay, okay, hold on.
Build up that speed, baby, and...
Nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope.
Okay, how do we do this?
Indy, do you have a plan?
And the animatronics on the ride are actually so impressive.
Hit the turbo.
What he's doing?
Okay, we gotta go.
Oh, it worked!
Oh, that's a bomb.
That's, that's a, okay, that's a mine.
We got it.
Okay.
Don't worry about the mines.
Don't worry about don't touch the mines.
Don't touch the mines.
Indy, don't touch up.
Don't touch up.
Indy, don't touch the mines.
Wait, what's in there?
Hold on.
Quick detour.
Oh, oops.
Actually, yeah, this is fine.
Oh, don't touch the mines.
Don't die either.
We're fine.
Okay, probably.
Another checkpoint!
Oh my gosh.
Kill him!
Oh, Indy, sorry.
Not you.
Not you, Indy.
Wait, I needed that heart.
Oh well.
We're fine.
Oh, there's that!
So close.
We almost didn't get that.
Whose bike is that?
Oh, shoot.
There's more guys.
We got them, we got them.
They'll never have fresh produce again!
Oh, okay, I forgot that that doesn't do anything.
They'll never eat again.
No survivors.
I really do feel like Godzilla in this game.
It kind of makes me want like a Godzilla rampage type game.
like this enough.
Oh, more guys?
Leave me alone.
I hate it.
The respawn is like kind of crazy on some of these guys sometimes, though.
Alright.
Open.
Ah!
Why did we do that?
Why did we open for more guys?
Oh, I need his hat, I think.
Yeah, I need his hat.
Okay.
You mean like Rampage?
Is there already a GIM?
Is there already a GIM I'm unaware of?
Rampage N64?
Oh!
Thank you!
Good money, good money.
I don't remember the other parts of the song.
Ouch!
Oh, I don't know.
didn't mean to become a plant.
Hold on, how do I get out of here?
Wait, I don't want to be a plant anymore.
Stop!
Uh-oh.
Okay, we're not trapped.
We're fine.
Just a bush.
What's this doing?
What'd that do?
What?
What that?
Oh, gosh.
Are you okay?
Oh, I dropped it.
Oh, it's like another collectible, I think.
Oh my gosh, I have one heart.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, ouch!
Aim of a...
Aim of the gods.
What is this?
Oh, that's just a gun, I think.
Okay.
There's so much going on in this little area.
.
It's so catchy.
I don't remember the next part though.
Ah!
The compass of your heart.
Yay!
Okay, there was some stuff.
I see them kind of like chilling in there.
You see that?
It's messed up.
Oh, okay, the shovel.
We grabbed this and then there was a shovel area right over here.
Here, here, here.
We dig in.
Dorko, thank you so much for the fire.
Good to thank you.
What is this?
Nice.
Oh, my God!
Where did you come from?
Oh, my gosh.
Okay, you got this, Papa.
He thought he could follow me, stupid.
dumb oh that's my dad oh excuse me i thought i landed on top of an officer please sir who was it me get in jail oh
raiders oh thank you i'm not ignoring i'm just playing the game but thank you thank you so much for for her for the uh redirect thank you so much Wait, didn't I have a...
Wait, I need a...
I need...
A wrench.
Well, where did I get one before?
And then I also got this.
What do I need this for?
Hmm.
Mysterious.
I don't think there was anything on this side, no?
No.
I don't remember.
So there was that thing.
Ah!
Oh, oh.
That's awkward.
Wait, did I lose?
I thought I lost...
Oh, I did lose the bazooka, I think.
I...
What else have I not done around here?
I mean, there's a few things but I'm like, well, how do I...
Let's see.
What do I need to blow up?
I don't see any...
There's this thing over here, too.
I guess we need to get this working.
Oh, I do blow these up.
Just...
Stop respawning!
You guys suck!
Okay.
I do need to go back in there, then.
Oh.
I like how...
drops money.
Wow.
Nice.
Okay.
And here.
Grab you.
Leave, leave, leave, leave, leave, leave, leave.
And just run past.
Run past everybody.
We don't care about them.
Run, run, run, run, run, run.
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
They are so obsessed with me.
Oh.
Well, that worked.
Okay.
That worked very nicely.
Grab my money?
Yeah, Jones is superhuman.
Sorry, collateral damage, sorry.
Oops.
I mean, destroy that, but whatever.
Look at that guy!
I don't think he cares.
What?
Do you think he cares?
Anyway, we keep going.
I need my bikes!
Pop on, pop on!
Ignore everybody else.
Ignore the elephants in the room.
Okay, hold on.
I'll also...
Hold on.
Okay, you get on that.
I get left.
Okay, you get right.
Oh, shoot.
Oh,
okay.
Okay, you get left.
Shoot.
Oh, no.
Papaya, you're like... Okay, I'll get this one.
Yeah!
Just go!
Oops, I didn't mean to jump.
Oh, my bike is dead.
Oh, I'm dead.
Something just exploded.
Oh, there are people literally sinking.
Um, we could...
Oh.
Uh, where are the...
Uh-oh.
Wait, oh no, oh, guys, guys, I think we have a problem.
Guys, I think we have a problem.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, no.
Okay, let's just run for it a little bit.
And, um, maybe they'll start dropping somewhere.
Oh, ha, but...
Oh.
Uh-oh, that doesn't seem good.
Oh my gosh!
I'm trapped.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, this is insanity.
I'm gonna lose all my money here for sure.
Woo!
Can I have them shoot the doors?
What is this?
Oh, there's more!
Oh, thank you.
Let's see.
What do we got going on in here?
It can definitely hit you in here.
Oh, jeez.
Why do they give...
Allow them to have guns?
Okay, if I climb up here, can I...
Okay, I need a bazooka, I'm pretty sure.
Okay, oh, they're just...
Everybody's just flying everywhere, and everywhere, and everyone, and anywhere, and any...
All the time.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
You just try to punch it?
Yeah, but who cares?
It's a Lego.
I've been able to destroy everything until now.
Where's my dad?
Oh, okay.
Oh, this is...
Ah!
Okay, we got one.
We got one.
Oh, I was still able to get it.
Oh, ish?
Wait, no way.
Oh, my God.
This is so hard.
I guess they give you guys so that you can...
um So that you can Get hearts wait i'm pressing the wrong button No, please please Please Okay How many times do i need to shoot it though?
Oh, there's more guys and they have their own bazookas No, stinking way.
What is this?
Trying to kill the guy in here.
Oh my gosh.
It's just insanity.
It's just actual insanity.
This is insane.
My buddy!
Oh my god.
We both died.
Oh, they come out!
And they start...
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh, okay.
At least I can grab one here.
This one's crazy.
This one is so crazy.
No, no, no.
Kill him, yeah.
Kill him.
Kill it.
Yeah, yeah.
And then he's gonna come out, right?
And then he's gonna be like, oh, pew, pew, pew.
Wait, where is he?
I'll get his ass.
I think I killed him.
This is like a money killer for real.
Oh my gosh, you just lose everything.
I'm losing it all!
Oh, there's no more!
The winner takes it all!
The loser has to fall.
Can I take one, please?
Thank you.
Oh, dang.
I was gaming for a second.
They're bankrupt, Digger.
What is this dang area?
Wait, why am I still shooting at that?
Oh, my God.
Okay.
If I die, you die with me.
I tripped him.
Please, please let that be enough.
Please, oh.
What are these?
What do you need me to do?
Why are they dancing?
Why are the flowers dancing?
Okay, I saw there was...
What?
Huh?
No, please, God.
No, God, please.
Papa, do something.
What am I supposed to do here?
When things dance, you need to build.
I know, but I'm pressing the build button and nothing's happening.
I am trying to build.
Oh, here we- oh.
They want me to build flowers?
Are you serious right now?
What?
Is this a real situation?
They were so tiny that I couldn't even tell that I needed to build anything.
Is this real?
No, please, build.
Please build.
Need a... Oh!
Oh my gosh, it's for a secret.
Uh-oh, Papa.
You're fine.
Oops, I'm not fine.
Sometimes where it resets you at is, like, messed up.
Let me try the hot, maybe?
But I don't think so.
I don't know why I'm building flowers, you guys.
I don't know.
How do I get out?
Do I need a bazooka for the door, maybe?
Oh, I don't have it anymore.
They're gonna come out.
They're gonna come out and they're gonna give me!
Ah!
Please!
Oh my god.
I don't know why I, like, live and then I die immediately after.
Finish the turret.
Is it because of that?
Is it actually?
I thought it was done.
I'll try.
Oh, I think Papa just died again.
This one?
Oh.
Wait.
There we go.
Oh my...
It was really that simple!
Oh my gosh.
Jump kick!
Oops.
Yeah!
Okay.
They really...
I think they like halved my money.
Even more so.
I think they, like, took so much of my money.
That was so...
That was so rough, man.
Why did it have to be that difficult?
Ever considered playing uncharted games?
It's on my list of games to play, so yes.
I really have given her a hat with hair.
Yeah.
Yeah, pretty lady.
She's like, oh my gosh.
She's really in rubble.
Planting flowers in a war zone.
I don't want to look at my amount.
Don't tell me.
I'm upset.
Oh wow, I got a good, I got half of it though.
It's not bad.
Indy is just that much of a hunker.
Yeah, he is.
Uh-oh.
Very inconspicuous.
Nobody notices.
Hold on, I'm gonna have a...
a throat mint.
That's my name.
Don't wear it out.
Not throat mint.
Wow, she really just took over her hair!
Oh.
Good discovery.
Wait, Indy, you could do the same thing.
Do they have...
Do they know it's me?
Oh, they're like circling me?
I guess if I touch them, maybe?
They'll know it's me?
Maybe?
I'm actually so confused.
Oops.
Oh, okay.
So yeah, as soon as I started attacking, they were like...
Okay.
Don't mind anybody!
Don't...
Wait, what was it?
What did that do?
Sir?
Oh, I do have to take these.
Oh my god, everything is just...
What is happening?
Everything is all happening at once.
Oh, I did a good dodge there, huh?
I didn't even...
I totally meant to do it.
So, it was really good.
Am I...
What is exploding, actually?
I'm not quite sure what the explosions are.
Oh, I missed him.
Ow!
Stop!
Stub it!
Ahaw!
Oopsie!
I don't know what the explosions are.
Yeah, Papa, keep them busy!
Keep them busy!
Wait, where am I?
Ah, dang it.
The chairs he's throwing?
throwing our explosive chairs?
It's pretty hardcore.
Ouch!
Okay.
No!
Throw!
Indy!
I'm literally like pressing the throw button and he just doesn't do it.
So frustrating!
There we go.
Finally!
God!
Golly!
Oh, he picked up a hat instead, is that what happened?
Oh, we just...
How did he live?
Oh, he threw him out...
Not the two-point turn.
The blip even has to...
A mosquito in my ear at 2 a.m.
Cool!
Well, surely they'll never follow us down.
here.
We can even...
Useless plane!
Useless!
Destroy!
Wait, what is this?
Whoa, I needed to destroy it.
Surely.
Wait, was I some...
Whoa!
Wait, I didn't finish exploring that side.
Ah, there we go.
The game was like, we know.
We know doofus.
Now get back over there and finish what you started.
Oh, the lever.
Can you do it?
Oh, the lever, punk.
1245.
That's very interesting.
What could it mean?
The numbers!
What do they mean?
Ah!
I have to probably get...
I have to make it 1245!
Ah, but I have to find a little...
Hold on.
Maybe this here?
I love that everything pays me.
It's the clock!
Yeah.
Gotta get the clock to 1245.
How?
Hmm.
Oh!
I just break the clock!
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
You just don't need the clock!
Hahaha!
sometimes.
So silly.
Do I put it here?
No?
Okay.
Just kidding.
Where does it go?
It's so heavy.
Uh...
Okay.
Well, now the clock won't work, I think.
I think I messed up the order of operations here.
Indiana Jones.
What are you doing, buddy?
Coin!
Now we can do it.
Are these?
Great.
What's that?
Oh my god.
Oh, they're dropping.
What the hell
is...
What is this red thing here?
Grab it.
There you go.
Oh my god.
They're bombing us.
Maybe they are!
I thought maybe...
They were...
Actually, I'm not quite sure.
Oh!
I thought it was like maybe a landmine, but I actually...
Oh my god!
It's so funny!
It's so terrifying at the same time!
This game is so...
What the hell?
Oh my gosh, all that burrow.
Dang.
Stinking...
Here they come from the sky!
Oh my gosh.
Let me have a gun.
Thank you.
This is scary.
Oh my gosh.
Let me out of here, please.
Not a moment of rest ever.
Oh my gosh.
Why do they even...
What's the point of...
of dropping bombs?
If you're just gonna...
Also send down men, I don't understand.
What's the point?
Okay, I think I need to dig, but I don't know where a shovel is.
Or do I need the parkour here?
Too whimsical for us literally getting...
Um, you know...
Rained upon.
Just saying game.
I don't feel very whimsical right now.
The outhouse?
You're a genius.
Thank you.
Oh wait.
I see you now.
I see.
Oh.
Dang it!
In obnoxious!
No!
Wait, did we break it with our fat ass just to rebuild it?
No way.
Just for me to do this all over again?
Okay.
Sure.
Is it only one person at a time, maybe?
Indy, don't do it!
Okay, thank goodness.
Indy, you're on your own, pal.
Wow, the f- Ah!
It's gonna say the fruits look so ripe!
Oh my gosh, there's another guy.
Indiana Jones just rebuilt it, it's Lego.
I believe in the...
Oh, how did he do that?
Wait a second, how did you do that?
Indy, how did you do that?
How'd you get over here?
Cute hat, thank you!
I'm Minky Anna Jones.
This looks suspicious, no?
Like I can parkour up it?
Not parkour.
Maybe it goes to nowhere.
Okay, let's keep going.
Oh, not my gun.
Don't waste it.
Okay.
Oh my gosh, again.
Please.
Please spare me.
This game is...
ruthless but it's honestly oh my god it's honestly like just so it's so unforgiving sometimes no
what is that oh nice shot papa nice
so funny
Oh, it's so funny.
Because it's like so violent.
Oh my god!
Oh, India died again.
There's no reason for it to be like this.
Alright, where does this go to?
Okay, I see an arrow.
Alright.
Oh, one out of three.
Okay, it's a generator.
Got it.
Okay, got it, got it, got it, got it.
Okay.
Two out of three.
Okay, nice, nice, nice.
Papa, I don't need you to stretch in your back every time, okay?
Oh, I'm wasting my gun!
Put it away!
Oh, I need to take this somewhere.
Where, though?
Oh, it's filling up with...
Uh...
Horn?
Oh, Indy, Indy, Indy, wait, no, Indy, Indy, Indy.
You're so limber.
Okay.
Gold.
I know sometimes I don't have to do these things, but sometimes I can't tell what I have to do.
What?
What I don't have to do.
You know what I mean?
Hmm.
Okay.
Alright.
Wait, take that.
That's some good money there.
Oh my god!
Okay.
Fine.
Okay, everything's fine.
Take care of them for your old pops, okay?
There we go.
Very good.
And I'll take...
That.
Please.
Okay.
Nope, please.
Okay, thank you.
Kaboom!
Holy cow!
Okay, alright.
Now what did we...
What was it?
I mean, did we need to fix something?
If we did, I did not see.
Oh, wait!
Oh my god, no!
It's far away.
I think we're okay.
Maybe.
Oh!
Oh, it opened up a thing.
Oh.
How did he jump like that?
Oh my god, oh my god.
Oh my god.
Ah!
Okay.
Everything's fine.
Everything's good.
Baby Gordon, thank you so much for the gift, dude!
First try.
What is it that needs repaired, though?
Oh, I see this part.
now.
Indy.
Aha!
Okay.
All right, all right, all right.
Oh, I thought.
Okay, now we need to repair something.
Okay.
I think there was a broken car, was there?
Let's see.
Oh!
Yes, you're right.
I think.
Well, there's a car.
Ah, it needs a steering wheel, of course!
Oh, oh, hello.
The way they come, it's so slow.
Oh my god!
Friendly fire.
I want this money over here.
what else does it need oh repair wait where did it land all right get an indie
this is good enough yeah oh my god wait no no no no no no wait is
oh wait didn't this actually happen in the movie Bye-bye.
Bye-bye.
Have a nice...
Wait, see you...
Wait, have a nice summer.
See you next fall.
Wait, what is...
Oh, did we have to fight planes now?
Ah!
Wait.
Uh-oh.
I'm about to die.
Oh, no.
What's happening here?
Oh, my God.
Oh, bird attack!
Nice!
We took them out somehow.
With the bird attack.
Wait, Papa, you... Oh, never mind.
Just kidding.
Bird strike.
Yeah!
It's perfect.
Oh my gosh.
Nice!
It's so funny that they die to their own things.
Alright, nice, nice, nice.
I mean, it makes sense.
It would actually make me very upset if they didn't because that would be...
Uh-oh, wait, did I lose the shovel?
Oh, I lost my shovel.
Oh, no, I lost my shovel.
No, I didn't!
This beach is huge!
New shovel, new shovel!
Papa, papa!
Watch out, papa.
Don't stand so close.
Anything in here?
These houses are so small.
I didn't see a third one.
Hmm.
I guess it's hidden somewhere.
Oh my gosh.
I can't jump.
There we go.
Wait.
Oh my god.
Papa!
We're fine, everything's good, everything's chill and cool.
Oh my gosh.
If I could...
If I knew how to do anything, actually...
Get out of my way!
He's like, I'll show you how to do it, son.
Oh, I have to show you how to do it, son.
Oh,
I am.
We almost had it.
Wait, oh no!
Um, that's not good.
Second bird strike!
Ah!
But like, where- well, how are they dropping the guys?
That's what I wonder.
How?
Wait, where's my dad?
Oh, there he is.
Now we need to find the third set of birds.
Probably on the other side, I imagine.
Oh.
Hello.
All right.
Over here, probably.
I forgot there was another side.
I also need more...
Oh, here we go.
I need more health.
Gibby!
Oh, there it is.
I was like, what did it give me?
I hear birds.
My ears do not deceive.
Oh, there they are.
Okay.
Surely they can't land.
Okay, on the boat.
If I'm tall enough.
Woohoo!
True Adventurer, baby!
Nice.
Get these pesky planes out of the way.
Oh my gosh, I almost didn't get True Adventurer.
Didn't I?
It was the end of the level.
Here comes the terrible sound!
Here it comes!
We got quite a few of these as well.
I think like five?
Yeah, nice.
Hold on, I'm gonna go unlock more people.
Here it comes!
Let's unlock more people!
Because Elsa has an office...
Wait, I really want this guy.
Bald Elsa!
Fresh officer!
Oh, I don't have another money yet.
Yeah, nice.
Wait, we unlocked Bald Elsa, right?
Wait, can I...
No, please!
Why won't anyone kiss me?
Please!
Why?
I'm so lonely!
I could kill somebody!
Wait, I saw a woman.
Where'd she go?
Oh!
Oh yeah, this is my original character, you guys.
Isn't he so cool?
Hi, Minto.
Hi!
We got the girl!
She does love me!
Wait, stranger.
Danger.
Maybe she has to be looking at me.
Wait, watch, watch, watch this, watch this, watch this.
Watch this, watch this.
Watch this.
Wait, why is she still out her butt for me.
watch this.
Turn around.
Turn.
Okay, watch this.
It wasn't a fluke.
I promise.
Let this go.
I just have to go find another lady.
You know what?
I'm done with ladies.
I don't need a relationship.
I'm a strong, independent Indiana Jones.
She's just in it for the whip.
Me when I'm trying to show off her cute girl.
Watch this.
Hoping for spooky games this month.
Any chance of death strand?
Death Stranding this month?
Maybe.
Oh my gosh, it's the end.
We're such a...
We're such an amateur.
Oh my, this guy is just in a full tank.
All the people, am I right?
I'm throwing them, I'm literally throwing them.
Tossing them around.
Hey, hey, I have a gun too.
Oh, I died.
So now.
Wait.
What happened to my gun?
I have one, and then I think I dropped it.
Um.
One second, we're exploring a little bit.
I'm getting money.
There's lots of things to explode in here.
Can I...
Yeah.
Oh!
Whoa, whoa, what is going on in here?
This goes to what?
This goes to here?
I'm a strong independent.
I don't have one of those, though.
Oh, okay, we're just gonna...
Okay, thanks, Gabe.
Oh, that's me shooting my gun.
Oh my gosh.
I don't think I can go up there, unfortunately.
There's even more, though.
I want to go up.
Oh, I didn't realize that was a ledge.
Ouch.
Oops, sorry.
Sorry, Sala.
Sorry, so sorry.
Oh, these are our friends.
These guys are on our side.
Except why are you aiming that at me, huh?
I'm not going to attack you.
Build, build, build.
Oh, wait, I don't have my Papa to read for me.
I'm illiterate.
Even though I'm a professor of this stuff, allegedly.
Indy, I need to see your license.
He's just showing you his cool gun.
Right, right, right, right, right.
Actually.
Oh!
What is it making?
Oh, I think I lost my gun.
Oh, but this is another thing I need to blow up.
Hmm.
I don't have a rocket launcher, unfortunately.
Is there one in here?
He's a professor of archaeology, not languages.
Well, he studied the wrong field, done.
Obviously.
I need to see his license.
Oh, sorry.
What are we creating?
Ah.
What's this go-to?
Okay.
Interesting.
Come on, come on, come on.
Oh, to here.
Oh, I need three of them.
Okay.
So, do I blow...
What?
I get this actually now, I think about it.
Was it from here?
Was it from you?
Oh!
Yeah.
Was it you?
I think it was the trucks, no?
Oh, sorry.
It's the trucks, but maybe not all of them have it.
Do you have one?
No, I think because it's already on fire.
Let's try another.
Excuse me.
The boss is horse.
Why is there a horse here?
Oh, there's also one up there.
Interesting.
Don't mind me.
Horse, watch your legs.
Umma, umma.
How do I get up there?
Woo!
Okay.
Kick me!
Oh wait, he likes me now.
Uh...
There we go.
Awesome.
Alrighty!
Nice to first try.
Excuse me!
Excuse me.
Gosh.
Very important.
archaeological work here in the works.
Wait, but how do I get the third one?
The third one is a real mystery here.
And your wimpy jumps are not making me feel good.
Sala has a shovel.
Does he?
Oh!
You're right.
Uh, it was in here, right?
Aha!
Oh, thank you.
I had no idea.
Thank you so much.
Alright, come back down!
That's a lot of stuff, I know you're in.
Okay.
Really?
Fine.
What's in here?
Ah, there it is!
But...
Not yet, not yet, not yet.
Not quite.
Oh, there's nothing.
Oh, okay.
Dang.
Oh, we're up here.
Oh, whoa.
What are we building?
Oh, he's hard at work.
Go bulldozer!
Thank you, everybody.
I will be taking my leave now.
Yes?
Oh,
my gosh.
Shagohad.
Wait.
This is really just a Metal Gear haul.
Oh.
grab your money finish building can't he go after oh my gosh oh thank you can't he go after somebody else instead
there's two people on this field wait do I drop this on him or oh I just drop it in general okay
oh my god
Oh, that was close.
Wait, what is this?
Is this a mine?
Oh, it is!
But...
Oh, it did do damage.
That's huge.
We're growing more flowers again.
What is... What is... What is this?
Ah, so sad.
Wait, here, too?
Send it here?
Yeah.
Shoot.
Like shoot.
Like, I'm right here and then you shoot me.
You know?
Like...
Dang it!
You miss!
How could you miss?
Okay, like, right here.
Can flowers bloom on the battle?
Field.
Maybe I jump on top.
Hello?
I'm right here.
Okay, cool.
Oop!
Okay, too high.
Ah!
Okay, it was worth blowing up for.
Some people are worth blowing up for.
Okay, nice.
Did it work?
Oh, it works!
Nice!
It worked, it worked.
Okay, I'm right here!
Okay.
Too high!
Whoa!
Nice!
Right here!
Too high!
I am a little lower.
Lower your expectations.
I didn't die though.
Oh, start building.
Sola again.
Oh wait!
Now we can kind of, like, look at this area.
Oh, I wanted to get that blue one.
But he can dig this.
Let's see.
Whatever's here.
Whoa.
What is this?
Actually, what is this?
It requires some sort of power-up that I do not have.
It's a mailbox.
I guess we can...
I still have more stuff with Mr...
Oh no!
Wait, I wonder what I would...
He like blows something up up here and then I...
Ah!
I've rolled the cart.
Wait, that's kind of fun.
Wait, I think we can do it ourselves!
Just kidding.
Yeah, we can do it ourselves.
Move out of the way.
YAHOO!
We'll grab this and then we'll keep going.
Cinematic camera.
I know it's so cool.
Alright, let's go.
That was fast.
Right here, right here!
Holy!
Oh my gosh.
me over i don't want to be stuck in a death loop please
um the thing that i need oh my gosh oh i need my horse
and horse kick me up thank you
okay i think the horse i don't think you can get the horse can you it wouldn't do that would they Oh wow, this is for a secret I thought it was for.
Okay, just kidding.
Definitely thought it was for the battle that we're currently going through at the moment.
No worries, though.
I would love to not be by this plan.
Thank you.
This game is just so unnecessarily violent sometimes.
I feel like...
something else?
There's that, obviously.
Alright, come on, horse, let's go!
They're not as fast as I thought they'd be.
They're definitely, like, running in slow motion kind of horses.
They're like, we're gonna kick your butt.
Oh, no, one of these again.
Oh.
They didn't even...
Okay.
I think they tripped.
I think they both tripped, like, trying to get on the...
on the bus.
That's fine.
Oh, Sala!
Sala, are you okay?
Oh, B2!
I also tripped!
Oh!
Yeah, they're fumbling hard.
Okay, Sala, this is, like, your chance to...
Okay.
You could have done anything except look at your hat.
You could have done literally anything.
And you chose to look at your hat.
That's fine.
Oh, that guy jumped over and then noked it.
It was...
It's fine.
It's a good hat.
I mean, I'm not denying that.
And I'm...
I appreciate a good hat.
Oh, that was smooth, Indy.
Come on, Zala!
Come on!
Wow, there's so many guys.
I like that I can just punch them off though.
Game over!
Not for me!
Yeah!
Definitely for him!
Oh,
I remember this part too, and they were like, Oh my gosh, Indy's dead!
Indy's dead!
What are we sad about?
Oh, my buddy.
Oh, it looked like he smooched him.
Move far, say him.
So the next one should be the last one, right?
Ah, I wasn't a true adventurer.
Oh, sorry, I forgot.
I have a lot.
Let's go try and buy another sexy lady and then I'll...
Then...
That'll be it.
Then we'll play.
I just want to buy a sexy lady.
It's my final chance!
Enemy butler.
Wait, where's enemy made?
Go, go!
Congrats, Mint, you destroyed the Shagohad once again.
I really felt like it.
Elsa in the desert.
What's Kazim?
Oh, is that God?
I forgot that this was like a subplot of this movie.
That there's like people that are actually like, Hi, we, um, we're, we're protecting the, the, the, we're protecting the Holy Grail.
I completely forgot these guys were in the movie.
They don't do anything.
They really don't do much.
In fact, even in this game, I'm, you're kind of just like, you're kind of just like, what are you?
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, hold on, hold on, hold on.
watch this
don't leave don't leave my sweet please no wait wait watch this watch this watch this watch this watch this I think I need to stand back a little bit more watch this watch this if I look at her with direct intent watch this watch this Please.
You're watching?
Yeah, good, good.
Oh, what's this?
I thought...
Oh my gosh, I thought this guy right here was Elmo.
You guys see it too?
It looks like Elmo, no?
Okay, this is the last one!
How exciting!
Like, from a glance, when he walked by, I was like, that's Elmo in my game.
Okay.
I don't think I've completed literally a single one of these, but that's fine.
Minto buying and then whipping girls?
It's one of my hobbies.
Can't unsee that Elmo ticked away.
What are they doing?
Oh.
Why do you sound French?
Hello.
We're all just chilling here.
Indy's behind my head.
I'm so sorry.
You can't see him.
Nice.
That was pretty smooth, I'd say.
Oh, wow.
They don't stop coming.
Turning it down a little, sorry.
That's everybody, right?
They won't be joining us again.
Seems to be the case.
Very nice.
Look, we have, like, a full party now.
Indy, why'd you jump in there?
Okay.
What is this thing?
Wait.
Everybody's in there.
Everybody's...
Okay.
Everybody has decided to go in there for some reason.
I want to be Indiana Jones, I want to be the main character.
It's a petting zoo or something.
Gosh, this game makes me so sick.
Oh, I'm shooting the gun.
I didn't mean to.
It's okay, we're on the last... last one.
I don't know what it is about this game.
him.
Hoi!
Close.
Oh, come on.
I'm literally touching that.
You think it's the camera motion?
I don't know what it is.
I'm usually not so bad with like, uh, like getting motion sick in games.
Ah, there we go.
If there was a way to turn a change frame rate though, I would, Unfortunately.
There is not.
Unfortunately.
This game has very minimal.
It's okay though.
I'm still having fun.
But it's just like.
I just need like a...
I did, like, close my eyes for a bit, you know?
Get in there.
Okay.
Right, left, up, right.
Drink water.
I am, I am.
No worries.
I've been drinking water the whole time.
Thank you, though.
Oh, yeah.
Me and Sala, the dream team.
Ow, I bit my tongue.
The dream to live.
Dude.
Destroy priceless artifacts.
What is this thing?
I'm so sorry I missed what your super chat said, but thank you so much for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Okay, what do I do with this thing?
Up and down motions, tracking, jumping.
It's fine.
Like I said, I was talking to a friend too, and they were like, I tried watching your Indiana Jones Lego playthrough, and I couldn't do it because the game made me so sick.
I was like, yeah, me too.
Sucks.
Do I have to...
Oh, I think we have to light this up.
on fire, so let's go grab the torch.
And then we can probably... For some reason we need to be directed to be able to read.
Oh, it's probably too dark!
Break time?
No, it's okay.
We're on the last chapter anyway.
It's okay.
Uh...
Was that right?
Heck yeah!
Sorry if watching it makes you feel a little biticky.
Just know you're not alone.
Misery, something, something, misery, company.
What is he like again?
Like, cool guys?
Or...
Aw, he's like, you're a grandpa.
Aw, man.
Sean Connery is cool.
He's a big boss.
You feel okay?
That's good.
Misery loves company.
Okay.
Nice!
Good hop!
And then the red one.
Minkiana is Toad's Worth.
I didn't expect it from the game, to be honest.
To feel this way.
But literally every stream of this of this playthrough has been like this.
Ah!
Oh!
Where's the grail?
Yeah.
Oh, uh-uh.
Oh, wait, do we get to pick the Grail?
That'd be so exciting.
Oh!
Oh my god!
This is- oh my god!
Wait!
There's a decapitated man and then they amputated my father?
This is so messed up!
And we're just gonna- We're just gonna be okay with that and continue our adventure.
Got it.
Wait, when did Indy get the book?
Oh.
How do I turn it off?
Wait.
Oh, wait.
I messed up.
Ow!
Uh-oh.
Okay, how do I turn it off?
Oh, well, shoot.
Oh my god, wait.
I want that.
That's, like, the ration to me right now.
Like, the Metal Gear ration.
Okay.
I won't do it though.
I know better.
Oh, we need a tiny...
We need a kid or a monkey.
Oh, I could get this easy.
Oh.
This... I think this game is screwing with me a little bit.
I don't know if it's possible.
Oh, sorry.
Indiana Jones, please move.
oh my
god wait did i have to turn this on or was it optional
there's not there's not oh my god indiana jones there is not enough room up here for the two of us
dang it that was so close
just the two of us Can make it up, we try, just the two of us.
Nice, nice, nice.
You and us.
Nice, nice.
Is that a hole?
I think so.
Okay.
He just really wanted to get so close.
I don't know what that's for, but we'll take it.
Oh, not yet.
Not yet.
Grab the loot first.
What are you doing?
Are you an amateur?
He wanted to experience the pain together.
It's quite romantic.
There's a piece over there.
And there's money here.
If I could jump behind there.
Again.
Whoa, sick tricks.
Oh, I think I need to make this move.
Okay.
Wait.
Or...
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Wait.
Oh wait.
Not ha ha ha ha ha.
Indy!
What?
What are you doing over there?
Oh wait.
Can you make that jump with us?
I can't make that jump by myself.
Okay, just kidding.
I don't think we can.
Wait.
How do I do?
I can't push this.
Can you whip it?
Whip it good?
No.
I didn't see anything else.
I think I might have to try and jump with this or something.
I don't know how else to do it.
It's time for me to go to work later, Mito.
How a good day of work!
Thanks for sticking around!
Oh,
wait, I put it here.
Okay.
Not close enough, maybe, to the edge.
Okay, hold on.
Okay.
Ha!
It would help to make the jump.
Okay.
I can't, I can't get it!
I wish
they would stop following each other because it's really...
It's really not so nice.
Okay, it may be here.
Oh wait!
Yeah!
Okay, awesome.
Awesome.
I got married this weekend.
And we played a few of your covers on the reception.
Many new wishes were made that evening.
Thanks for being awesome.
Um, congratulations!
What the heck?
My?
My songs?
I'm sorry.
I hope people liked it.
What was the point of this thing then?
Last from the past.
Everybody's seen my favorite maze playing something so dear to my childhood.
Have you had fun?
Thank you so much!
Thank you, thank you!
Thanks for the super chat.
And I'm having fun.
Thank you.
Oh!
There we go.
Okay.
My bad.
Don't worry about it.
Okay, let's see.
Left, right, middle.
Okay, easy.
Whoa!
Into this.
I don't remember any of them.
I don't remember any of this part for...
The Last Crusade?
The Trials or whatever?
Oh, here.
You think we can make it?
Oh, yeah.
I like these, like, very Lego-colored.
They're my favorite part, actually.
How they're just why it is so bright, you know?
It's so funny.
I want that.
Holy moly, this area is actually humongous.
Oh, Sala fell, so it's a good thing we did that.
The purple, I know, I want to get it.
Snakes!
Why is there gonna be snakes?
Thanks.
Oh, oh.
Oops.
Oh, oh, oh, Andy.
Indiana Jones.
Okay.
I wanted to switch to him, but I...
All right.
Careful.
Easy now.
This is just a place to give money.
Sounds good.
I love that.
It's like Roblox.
Oof.
Welcome back.
Thank you.
And why he orpul?
Okay, we're gonna get this first try.
Did you see that?
We do be gaming sometimes.
Oh, gosh, that, oh my gosh.
we almost did not make that because somebody
we think okay it looks like I can light a fire in there so I gotta jump to the other side okay there we go nice so this will keep the snakes away from for eternity good job I don't like that I can hear them like this sounds like spaghetti not spaghetti mac and cheese when you stir the mac and cheese and cheese.
Definitely getting that kind of vibe.
First try!
First try, first try.
I wish I could ride that so I could get the coins on there, but whatever.
Oh, wow.
That's all that there was?
But, this part, too.
I think I can't do this because I don't have a person with, like, a eternal wrench.
Also, why?
Oh, it's not sticking out.
Oh, that's what...
I was like, why can't I grab that?
Ah, yeah.
I think I can't fix that.
So that stays...
That's inside.
And so I can't go upwards.
What's up there anyway?
Oh, it's just a chest.
Okay.
Hi.
Hey.
Oh, no.
This is, like, the worst camera angle ever.
Okay.
Hey.
Eight!
Oh!
Wait!
Depth, my depth perception, everybody!
Pray for me!
Eight!
Oh, dang it.
Oh, that's fine, that's fine.
Eight!
Ah, that's fine, that's fine, that's fine.
Oh my god, Zala, you almost didn't make it, buddy!
Oh!
What did that spell?
Close!
Busters!
Tempting.
Never mind.
It's not worth the money.
We'll lose more than we will gain.
Oh, I thought I saw a light back there, but I think it's just like the way that the light is.
This is like looking so cinematic, no?
Maybe I do need to go over there, though.
I can't make this, can I?
Is this the invisible bridge?
Oh my gosh.
Wait, but it...
Wait, look at it, too.
Like, look at the...
Like, it looks...
Oh, it looks so cool.
Sorry.
I just thought it looked neat.
I just thought...
I thought it was neat.
That's all.
Yee-hoo!
That's our first one.
Yikes.
Floating like a real ghost.
I do do that.
Sometimes.
It takes a lot.
Oh, it doesn't take a lot of energy, but it's just like...
I'd rather save my, you know...
If I use too much energy, you guys won't be able to see me.
I'll be like a little wisp like you guys.
That's why I'm always high.
haunting so much that I can be in this form and all.
I'm pushing, I'm pushing, I'm pushing.
What's it showing?
Is it showing the bridge?
Cool.
Nice.
Too much junk in the trunk to float.
Stop.
It's my insecurity.
My big butt's an insecurity.
Oh, I need another torch.
Okay, hold on.
We can do this one.
I just gotta go find one.
Just gotta go find the torch.
I think it was at the very beginning, though.
We backtracked just a tad.
Look, you can even see it in the distance.
Kind of as like a hint.
Will we make it, though?
That's another question.
Hugh Jass is calling you.
Will you pick up?
I don't know.
What's he got to say?
I can't see Sala.
Sala.
Oh my god.
Wait, I can't see.
I think it was this.
This.
Oh, I messed up.
Sala, move!
You stand here.
I stand.
Here.
He got closer.
Easy!
What is this now?
Oh, you can see it!
So cool!
So, so cool.
Have faith.
Oh my god.
Hey!
We're here.
You want me to move!
Oh my god, he's dying!
He's laughing!
Oh my god!
Final boss?
Oh my god.
Hey, hey, chill out!
Chill out, buddy!
Okay, I need you to dig.
Dig.
Put it in here...
And... home?
How do I know which one though?
Wait a second.
What am I supposed to know which one?
Ah, yippee!
What do you have to say?
Middle, up, left, left.
A cup of a carpenter.
Isn't it like the one that's not super fancy and...
It looks kinda bad.
No offense to it.
You okay there buddy?
Kiss me!
Just kidding.
Not you.
Sorry.
Oh, lots of money in here.
I love grave robbing!
Stop bullying him.
That- is that one, right?
It's this one, right here.
That one that's not very pretty.
The music is so urgent.
We're okay!
Here we go!
Bottoms up!
I wonder what happens if we were to, like, die.
Or if we picked the wrong one, what would happen?
Oh my god, give it to my legless father, please!
She's trying to seduce him.
Oh, wow.
He didn't even attempt to save her.
Wait, that's it.
Oh, my God.
Wait.
In the movie, he, like...
Oh, I'm sorry.
I forgot to warn you.
He definitely goes back for her.
Oh my gosh!
Let's finish the story!
Roll credits.
Yeah!
Woohoo!
We all made it out alive!
All of us!
See ya!
We don't want to beat ya!
Have a nice summer!
See you next fall!
Why is he doing that?
Why is he doing that to the horse?
Tags!
Why is he doing that?
Does he feel so good with his legs again?
Okay, I'm gonna get copyright struck.
We're at 64.8%.
Wait, it's so little, actually.
Yay!
I guess it's so low because, uh...
Shortbound, because, uh...
The artifacts, mostly.
Bazooka Troopa.
I can't afford him.
Well, no, we'll get this guy.
Wait!
We have some people that are locked!
Wait, how?
The Grail Knight is 100,000!
I want...
I want him.
Yay!
Well, I had no intentions on, like, 100%ing the game, so I think it's okay, you know?
To leave as is.
This was fun.
There are some bonus stages.
Who the hell are you?
Wait, come here.
I'm trying to get to see your face.
Oh, wait, what were you doing?
Is this...
Oh, oh, oh, I thought you were doing a boogie.
They're boogieing, you're boogie.
Astrobot, but Lego.
Yeah!
Yay, platforming games!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
This was so much fun though, despite it making me feel a little icky.
I still had a lot of fun, so.
Um, thank you guys for joining me for the little, we kind of of like it was like a speed run of each movie except it was also longer than each movie so it wasn't really a speed run oh oh shoot wait i missed what your super chat said virulent it was as something you can just send it as a chat it was something like about other lego games i saw thank you thank you thank you thank you
about nine-ish hours of playtime yeah yeah thanks minkiana such a fun game belongs in a museum yeah thank you so much dargo thank you thank you thank you thank you do lego indiana jones too as well how what what even i think you can watch all the cut scenes in order somewhere in the college There is a movie theater,
so...
I asked if I wonder if you...
Newer Lego games will make you nauseous.
I wonder too, I wonder...
Thanks for the stream and congrats on completing your 31st!
I think you... I think you're right!
Faken it, I think you're right.
I think it is my 31st game.
It's what, October?
We have three months to finish 20 more games?
No, well, thank you so much for the 20 games!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
100% completion is 20 hours.
And what?
We're about at, like, nine-ish hours, so...
Another...
Holy moly.
Kiss!
Hot dog indeed.
Try, Princess, thank you.
Oh, ah.
Oh, this is so fun!
I love Legos, and I love Indiana Jones, so this was a lot of fun.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you.
Congrats, Mito.
Cool.
We beat it.
Lego Indiana Jones.
It's fun, Mito.
I hope you check out other classic Legos.
Yes!
Oh, wait.
Sorry.
I'm not trying to be destructive.
I'm trying to be hot and sexy.
I'm trying to woo a lady.
Um, what was I saying?
Oh, yeah.
I definitely want to play the other Lego games.
Um, maybe just like a bit of a break.
I might like kind of see what they look like like I might look them up on YouTube first to see kind of what the gameplay style and like how it how it would might maybe make me feel you know what I mean gosh we only got 67 out of 180 treasure boxes that's crazy hmm You can see how your eyes adjust to it too.
I don't know if it's like, I was wondering, I was like, is it the camera angles?
Is it the frame rate?
Is it the colors?
Like, there's just something really, something about it.
As much as I want to be like, yeah, yeah, yeah.
But the last two times I was so low energy and it was because the game was just making me so sick.
But I definitely want to play Lego Batman.
If anything.
It's cursed.
Yeah, I want to play a game with the Lego voice acting.
Look at her hips, man.
Why are you walking like that for a Lego lady?
Look at her hips.
Look at her hips, man.
There ain't no reason to be walking so sexy like that, madame.
I'm trying to grab her.
Try to grab her.
This is me.
This is me when I see a cute girl.
on the streets.
I'm like
anyway.
Thank you guys.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
And I don't really it's not like there's like a cutscene or anything, so I don't really know how to end it, but I'm just gonna say Lego.
My ego!
Vito!
Thank you guys for the stream.
I hope you had fun.
I had fun.
I will see you guys when I see you next.
It's a Vito.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, bye bye, bye, bye, bye.
Oh, wait, I have to exit the game.
I forgot.
My stream deck doesn't work.
I have to go back.
I have to exit the game and exit to Windows.
I have to do all this first.
So I have access.
Oh.
What?
Are we good?
So I have access to my mouse.
Bye bye, bye, bye, bye.
Thank you!
Bye bye!